هديه الدبابات الثمينه من المانيا وامريكا
وغيرهما لم تكفي كيف فالرئيس الاوكرانيز
الانسكي يطمع الان بصواريخ بعيده المدى
ومقاتلات جويه بهدف التصدي للقوات الروسيه
التي تقاتل على اراضيها
اكبر شركات تصنيع السلاح في العالم للدخول
على خط الازمه لكن مارتن الامريكيه
المصنعه لمقاتلات اف 16 اعلنت عن
استعدادها لزياده انتاج تلك المقاتلات دون
التدخل في اي محادثات لتزويج اوكرانيا بها
وانما ستعوض البلدان التي ستدعم اوكرانيا
عبر ارسال واحده من اشرس المقاتلات وافقا
ما كتبته صحيفه الفاينشل تايمز
سنزيد من انتاج طائره اف 16 لمساعده اي
دوله تختار القيام بعمليات لتلك الطائرات
للمساعده في الصراع القائم في اوكرانيا
لن تنفذ من دون مباركه البيت الابيض فلا
يحق لاي دوله تمتلك المقاتلات الامريكيه
ان ترسلها لدوله الثالثه دون موافقه
واشنطن والتي ما زالت ثابته على موقفها
رافضه لارسال اف 16 اوكرانيا خوفا من ان
تتحول لاداه انتقام تهاجم بها كيف اراضي
روسيا لكن لا ننسى انه واشنطن كانت ترفض
سابقا ارسل الدبابات قبل ان يتغير موقفها
نحن على اتصال المتضمن مع الاوكرانيين
بشان احتياجاتهم وطلباتهم وفي هذا الوقت
ليس لدينا ما نعلن عنه بخصوص طائرات اف 16
مساعدات عسكريه مستمره يقدمها الغرب
لاوكرانيا منذ بدايه الزحف الروسي لم تصبح
محل جدلا كما الان كونها كانت في الغالب
اسلحه للدفاع عن النفس الا ان نتغير منح
المساعدات باتجاه الاسلحه الهجوميه ابتداء
بدبابات ابرامز فتح الحديث حول خطوه اكبر
واخطر فالحرب طالت لنحو عام من دون دبابات
او مقاتلات فكيف ان وصلت كل هذا الاكياف
عمر العربيه